hi all tim ferriss here i'm going to
answer a question about relationships i
may or may not be qualified to answer
this
uh but it's more of a suggestion topics
on how
you consciously improve your
relationship and that would be with your
significant other
even when things are really good how to
dig up uncomfortable topics
with your partner and willfully engage
in them that's an important part
finances emotions empathizing getting
from 75 to 90
or 99 in terms of relationship quality
that's from frank
all right so i'm going to suggest a
number of tools that have been helpful
to me
and helpful to my girlfriend
but it's important to keep in mind we've
been in a relationship for three years
so you may want to talk
to people who have more experience both
with clients and in their own
relationships
a couple of recommendations you can go
to tim.blog slash podcast and listen to
interviews that i've done with esther
perel she's fantastic
you can listen to the second interview i
did with brene brown
also outstanding both of these touch on
a lot of relationship tools and dynamics
and jim detmer d-e-t-h-m-e-r
also where we talk about the first tool
i want to discuss
and that is the work by byron katie
and the work is a sequence of steps you
can take
to question beliefs and you can use this
in your own life
you can use this in a couple's context
but if you're upset about something if
you are sensitive about something it
really just takes
your beliefs these thoughts we take to
be true
and puts them under a microscope and the
steps in brief
are can i know this is true whatever
that belief is
can i absolutely know this is true
that's number two and then some
variation of
who am i when i have this belief what do
i feel
how do i react etc and then the last is
who would i be
without this belief how would i feel
without this belief
and i'm simplifying for the purposes of
this video but
you can find all these steps and more on
byron katie's
website for the work and i suggest you
take a look at it
because it is very difficult to engage
with difficult topics
if you are easily triggered if you are
already
lobster red with a psychic sunburn of
some type where if even the slightest
poke will set you off
so the work is really helpful
both before conversations and after if
you're really fired up in a conversation
and you think your partner is selfish or
that they are entitled
or fill in the blank whatever it might
be it's very helpful to go through this
process
a part of which is called turn arounds
so a turnaround is taking the belief
let's just say it is
so and so is entitled and then you will
change that phrase and you'll have to
pick or find
say three pieces of evidence to support
it as a thought exercise
the way you turn it around there are
multiple formats instead of so and so is
entitled you might say i am entitled and
then you come up with three
pieces of evidence or more and then you
might turn around and say so and so is
not entitled
and you come up with three pieces of
evidence to support that
and so on and so forth and going through
this process
is incredibly valuable because
it trains you to scrutinize these things
you take to be true
and very often as soon as you start to
poke and prod you realize that they're
not as defensible
as you initially thought so that's tool
number one
tool number two would take very
seriously
how you communicate the words you use
non-violent communication
i think it's marshall rosenberg we'll
have the correct
name and so on in the description if i
mess that up
uh was recommended to be by neil strauss
the eight time maybe ten time
new york times bestselling author and a
friend of mine which he found very
helpful
and it's really just a format again a
format a template
for communicating in a way that is less
likely to provoke
a strong negative emotional reaction
right so
one approach to that is really owning
just about everything and making it
that which a video would record so when
x y and z happened or when i see x y and
z something that is beyond debate
the facts i feel a b and c
also beyond debate i feel a b and c
right
the story i make up around that
is blah blah blah right so you're
calling it a story which also
is less accused story so the story i
make up around it is that
you don't care about how i feel so
you're leaving the dishes
undone right to use a cliched example
and
i have a need for blah blah blah
whatever it might be right
safety to feel heard who knows what it
is the story is my story
i understand i could be making it up i
probably am
but would you be willing to x and the x
is a specific request
this is important it's a specific ask
because otherwise you're just
complaining and it's very easy
to get into a spiral to lock horns and
just go nowhere with your partner
if you're simply pointing out problems
and this is super common i mean my
girlfriend and i do it all the time
but as a practice we are trying to
condition ourselves to always have a
specific ask would you mind
doing a when you do be
taking five minutes to do that then you
can have a discussion about it
but it's presented in a way that isn't
poking someone in the chest
making a value judgment so those are a
few basic
or i should say fundamental tools that
are incredibly powerful and versatile
that you can apply both to your
relationship and to your life overall
so i hope you find them useful
you